on a à peu près au chiffre est à quatre
millions cinq le nombre de victimes au
plan international et le ms dit c'est à
minima 3 fois plus donc ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que quand on a
relativisé en nous parlant de grippe
asiatique enfin on peut toujours trouver
effectivement des éléments pour dire que
la médiatisation avec les chaînes
continuent tout un ensemble de facteurs
font qu'on a une perception différente
c'est la première fois que tout le monde
entier se trouvaient confinées c'est
aussi des éléments à prendre en compte
mais je dirais que dire aujourd'hui
qu'il y à peu près 12 à 15 millions de
personnes ils sont mortes au jour
d'aujourd'hui de lakovic 19 il y a eu
l'amplification des précarités des
vulnérabilités et rapport de l'oit et
sont de ce point de vue il est tellement
accablant donc la réalité de cette
pandémie c'était un phénomène global
total me paraît relever d'une approche
un peu différente de ce que serait par
exemple le cancer l'obésité enfin qu'on
considère aussi comme un phénomène
épidémique puisque c'est toucher 90
personnes
[Musique]